this means that we can take our lives
back family dr patrick phillips medical
license has been restricted since the
fall as part of his suspension the
northern ontario physician isn't allowed
to prescribe ivermectin for covid but
global news has learned the doctor is
now a director of a new provincial
telehealth service canadian coveted
telehealth inc offering the
anti-parasitic drug it's not been
approved for use in covet 19 it's been
studied pretty extensively it's been
shown to be quite problematic and the
website services aren't cheap from 150
dollars for covid prevention to almost
400 for a complex covered consultation
according to phillips lawyer he has
never issued a prescription for
ivermecton through the service when
asked about the telehealth network
prescribing the drug global news was
told the company does not control what
doctors give out while philip's
involvement and the existence of the
service isn't breaking any laws health
law expert timothy caulfield says it's a
loophole that needs to be closed it
creates confusion among the general
public and could do real harm if if
patients think that this is protecting
them or is the therapy that is actually
going to be effective after global news
reported on canadian doctors accused of
providing unproven covent information
and in some cases falsifying masks and
vaccine exemptions last week ontario's
minister of health demanded the
province's college of physicians and
surgeons cracked down including
reviewing the licenses of physicians
found to be spreading misinformation of
more than 40 doctors the college is
investigating at least two are involved
in a group closely associated with the
telehealth service phillips is a
director of still the college says its
hands are tied when it comes to a
business it's incumbent on them
to
very specifically
advise
the ministry
of what legislative changes it needs
ontario's health ministry is giving the
college the green light telling global
it must investigate whether it's an
individual or business someone has got
to fix this
it erodes public trust in our health
care system during a health care
emergency concerned anything less puts
patients at risk jamie marrocker global
news toronto